[Música]
bom gente boa tarde todo mundo viu que a
gente foi apresentado ante a banda
carioca de campinas e antes de tudo o
que aprontou com isso a vocês quem é que
está feliz hoje feliz mesmo feliz
a gente está muito feliz de estar aqui é
que não sei se vocês sabem mas a gente é
uma banda de rock autoral de campinas
primeiro uma banda de rock então já
começa errado
segundo aquela boca de uma banda de rock
autoral que também já não é muito
difícil uma banda de rock hotel de
campinas
nenhuma cidade expoente do rock no
brasil
e a gente fica muito feliz de estar aqui
porque basicamente a nossa função como
banda de rock autoral é passar a
mensagem para as pessoas e fazer com que
elas têm que mudar um pouco da atitude
delas a partir de nossas músicas ser
computado o evento como esse que o
slogan agente da mudança é uma coisa
muito gratificante pra gente e pensando
em tudo isso é pensar em tudo isso é
nessa história de mudança a gente fez
uma música chamada sala de estar que
basicamente ela fala que a cada minuto
que passa na sala de estar é um minuto
mais longe do da coisa que você mais
quer
[Música]
é
agora chegou a sua hora
[Música]
sob o sol
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoje guarda
ó
[Música]
dança - canal ontem no rio eo asa só
senão lá já
o faraó
i am
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a roche
ó
a grade
já a a
o amor
[Música]
ó
você
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoje
[Música]
boy with sam
não sou eu
[Música]
ó
obrigado e aí como se sentirão causa um
leve com furto ele às vezes me pego
pensando a todos que comemos na sala de
estar aí ó rolanda rede social ficou um
tempão lá e a gente tenta fazer essa
mudança como greve falou de mover as
pessoas com a nossa palavra é é a
próxima música que a gente vai mostrar
pra vocês é nosso primeiro lp chama
descubra o spotify nas outras redes
extremistas quem quiser conhecer pega lá
e essa música fala um pouco sobre a
mudança que várias vezes a gente tenta
mudar
só que não é tão fácil né as coisas não
são como a gente espera que seja assim e
vamos sair daqui bom levantar do sofá e
fazer alguma outra coisa
de repente a gente se vê preso ali e
essa próxima música que chama horizonte
é sobre essa essa subida do herói é que
a gente fala sobre tentar essa situação
essa zona de conforto e traz essa
melhoria pessoal para cada um
eu não sei o mal o homem paulo gonçalves
paulo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ficou bom
os ingressos
[Aplausos]
o álbum é contínuo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o dia longe o zinho sentir
o gol
[Música]
ó zé e gol
ae
ó
[Música]
o bagulho
[Aplausos]